hello everyone welcome to this session
of blockchain interview questions my
name is saurabh and i'm part of the
simply learn team so let's get started
and understand what kind of interview
questions can come for a blockchain
interview so let's start with certain
beginner level questions now when you
face a blockchain interview you can get
different variety of questions so we
will be covering that what kind of
questions can be asked at each level
intermediate and expert level so one of
the few questions which you could be
asked is what is the difference between
blockchain and hyperledger blockchain is
basically the underlying concept
blockchain is a decentralized technology
of immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography whereas
hyperledger is a platform or an
organization that allows people to build
private blockchain so basically
blockchain is a concept is a technology
using blockchain you can build public
and private blockchains but hyperledger
is a specific technology which allows
you to build only private blockchains
now blockchain is divided into public
private and consortium blockchains
hyperledger is specifically a private
blockchain technology with access to
blockchain data is limited to predefined
users and it is defined using certain
configurations and programming
blockchain can be used in multiple
fields like business governments
healthcare other different kind of
domains and etc hyper ledger is
primarily used in blockchain for
enterprise based solutions so wherever
we are talking about public blockchain
is like usage of blockchain on internet
and hyper ledger based blockchain
solutions are solutions which are meant
for internet within an organization
within a corporation second how do you
explain blockchain technology to someone
who doesn't know it so basically in
simple terms blockchain technology is a
distributed ledger which stores
transaction details in the form of
immutable records non-modifiable records
which are called blocks which are
secured using cryptography so in order
to explain simplistically let's consider
an example of a school where blockchain
is similar to a digital report card of a
student now each block contains students
records which has a label stating the
date and time of when the record was
entered or when the record was
registered on the blockchain now neither
the teacher nor the student can modify
the details of the block cannot modify
the record of report cards therefore the
record becomes non-modifiable immutable
also the teacher owns a private key that
allows him or her to make new records
and the student owns a public key to
view and access the report card at any
time so basically the teacher owns the
right to update the record but the
student only owns the right to view the
record now this method makes the data
both active and secure and this is what
blockchain brings on the table these are
the primary attributes for which
blockchain is getting widely adopted to
have immutable records available for
view to the public and available for
updating in an untemperable way now what
is a merkle tree merkle tree is a data
structure which is used for verifying a
block it is in a form of a binary tree
containing cryptographic hashes of each
block so basically a merkle tree is
structured similar to a binary tree each
leaf node is a hash of a block of
transactional data so each leaf node is
basically a transaction which is hashed
and each non-leaf node is a hash of its
leaf node so basically hash a a is the
hash of two blocks a and hash b merkel
root or the hash root is the final hash
of all the transaction hashes so
basically merkel root is the hash of
hash a a and hash bb so it encompasses
all the transactions which are
underlying all the non-leaf nodes what
do you mean by blocks in the blockchain
technology what is the definition of a
block so blockchain is a distributed
database of immutable records called
blocks which are secured using
cryptography now as you see there are
the certain attributes of a block which
are displayed here you have previous
hash transaction details nonce and a
target hash value a block is like a
record of transactions each time a block
is verified it gets recorded in
chronological order on the main
blockchain so as you can see as it is
represented over here every time a new
block is verified it gets added to the
main blockchain with all those
attributes populated now once the data
is recorded it cannot be modified it
cannot be changed now another question
which could come into your interview is
how is blockchain distributed ledger
different from a traditional ledger it
is a very important question we need to
know the basic difference and
justification if we have to move from a
traditional database to a blockchain
based distributed ledger what benefit it
bring on the table so certain
differences which are very visible are
transparency blockchain distributed
ledger is highly transparent as compared
to traditional database distributed
ledgers are irreversible once any
information is registered on a
distributed ledger cannot be modified
whereas on a traditional ledger it is
reversible basically distributed ledger
is more secure it uses cryptography
every transaction is hashed and recorded
in a traditional ledger the security can
be compromised in a distributed ledger
there is no central authority it's a
distributed system the participants of
the network holds the authority to
maintain the sanity of the network and
are responsible for validating the
transactions whereas traditional ledgers
are based on the concept of centralized
authority and control and all the
transactions are controlled by the
centralized authority in a distributed
ledger identities are unknown and are
hidden whereas in a traditional ledger
identities of all the participants have
to be known before the transaction can
happen in a distributed ledger there is
not a single point of failure as the
data is distributed information is
shared across multiple nodes even if a
single node fails the other nodes carry
the same copy of the information whereas
in a traditional ledger in a centralized
database ledger based system that
particular system becomes a single point
of failure if the single system crashes
the entire application or the entire
network comes to a standstill ability to
modify data no once the data or a
transaction is registered it cannot be
altered in a traditional ledger it is
possible how validation is done so in a
distributed ledger it is done by the
participants of the network in a
traditional ledger it is controlled by
the centralized authority copy of ledger
is shared amongst all the participants
of a distributed ledger each participant
consists the same information in the
ledger in a traditional ledger only a
single copy is maintained at a
centralized location it is not shared
amongst all the participants thereby
again it remains as a single point of
failure if you have any queries you can
put your comments in the comments
section of this video and we will
definitely come back to you how can you
identify a block what are the attributes
of a block in order to understand it so
every block consists of four fields it
holds the hash value of the previous
block therefore it gets linked in a
blockchain it contains the details of
the aggregated transactions which are
aggregated in the block it has a value
called non nonce is a random value which
is used to vary the value of the hash in
order to generate the hash value less
than the target and then finally you
have a hash of the block itself it is
the digital signature of this block a
unique hash for this block it is a
alphanumeric value which is used to
identify a block so that is the identity
of the block the hash address is the
unique identification of a block it is a
hex value of 64 characters that has both
letters and digit it is obtained by
using sha-256 algorithm now this is the
way it is structured the hash of the
previous block the transaction data and
the nouns consolidate the header of the
block they all together
are passed through a hashing function
and then the hash value the digital
signature of the block is then generated
what is cryptography and what is its
role in blockchain blockchain uses
cryptography primarily to secure users
identities and ensure the transactions
are done safely with the hash function
so all the user identities and the
transaction on a blockchain are
encrypted cryptography uses public and
private keys to encrypt and decrypt data
so basically it uses the public and
private key infrastructure in order to
maintain the encryption of the
information on a blockchain network in
blockchain network public key can be
shared with all the bitcoin users all
the blockchain users so public key is
just like your address which you can
share it with anyone but a private key
is like your password it is kept secret
with the user so basically blockchain
uses cryptography to secure user
identities and ensure transactions are
done safely and how does it do it it
uses sha-256 algorithm which is secure
which provides a unique hash output for
every input and it is a very popular
algorithm the basic feature of sha-256
is that whatever input you pass it will
give you a standard output alphanumeric
output of 64 characters so basically it
is a one-way function you can derive an
encrypted value from the input but you
can't do vice versa now what are the
different types of blockchains which
exist there are three different types of
blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain and consortium blockchain
public blockchain ledgers are visible to
all the users on the internet and any
user can verify and add a block of
transactions to the blockchain basically
it's publicly available anyone can
participate in the network and get
hooked up so examples are bitcoin and
ethereum private blockchain ledgers are
visible to all the users on the internet
but only specific users in the
organization can verify an ad
transaction so it's a kind of a
permissioned blockchain though the
information can be available publicly
but the controllers and the validators
of the blockchain are within the
organizations and are pre-determined the
example is block stack consortium
blockchain here the consensus process is
controlled by only specific nodes
however ledgers are visible to all the
participants in the consortium
blockchain example is ripple now what
happens when you try to deploy a file
with multiple contracts in blockchain
deploying a file with multiple contracts
is not possible the compiler only
deploys the last contract from the
uploaded file and the remaining
contracts are neglected and this is the
way a smart contract is deployed on a
blockchain network now very interesting
question what is a genesis block it's a
very important question and could be
asked in an interview multiple times so
basically genesis block is the first
block in the blockchain which is also
known as block zero so as you can see
the sequence number of this block is
zero and in blockchain it is the only
block that does not refer to any
previous block so the hash value of the
previous block will be all zeros because
it is the first block also it defines
parameters of the blockchain such as
level of difficulty consensus mechanisms
etc to mine the block so basically it
defines the primary attributes of the
blockchain which is gonna get initiated
from the genesis block onwards now let's
look at some of the questions which
would come if you are at an intermediate
level now how is the hash of a block
signature generated in blockchain to
generate a digital signature transaction
details are passed through a one-way
hashing function for example sha-256
then the output value is passed through
a signature algorithm like ecdsa with
the user's private key then the
encrypted hash along with the other
information such as the hashing
algorithm is called as the digitally
signed document and is called the
digital signature so this is the entire
process of generating a digitally signed
block list down some of the extensively
used cryptographic algorithms these are
the few popular algorithms which are
extensively used sha-256 bitcoin uses it
it has ethereum uses it rsa is one of
the other popular algorithm blowfish
triple des so it's very important to
memorize these algorithms the names of
these algorithms when asked and she 256
and at hash are used in two of the
popular public blockchain networks what
is a smart contract and lists some of
its application so smart contracts are
self-executing contracts these are
basically digital contracts which
contains the terms and conditions of an
agreement between two parties between
two peers now some of the applications
can be used in transportation where
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
using smart contracts so as there's a
movement of goods and it is exchanging
hands between different parties there
could be need of a contract and a smart
contract between the parties it is also
used in protecting copyrighted content
like music or books or the literature
which you have written so smart
contracts can protect the ownership
rights it can also be used in insurance
it can be used to identify false claims
and prevent forgeries employment
contract smart contracts can be helpful
to facilitate wage payments and it can
be used as a proof of employment now
another important question what is it
network and how many ethereum networks
are you familiar with ethereum is a
blockchain based distributed computing
platform featuring smart contract
functionality that enable users to
create and deploy their decentralized
applications called daps there are three
types of network in ethereum live
network the main net then there are a
couple of test networks like robsten
coven and rink b and then you can also
create your own private network using
ethereum smart contracts are deployed on
the main network they are publicly
available and can be used by others also
test networks allows you to run your
smart contracts on a test net validate
the gas which is being used you can just
use these test networks as the main net
deploy your contracts verify your
decentralized application and then move
on to the main net private networks are
those which are not connected to the
main network which run within the
premises of the organization but carry
the features of an ethereum network now
where do nodes run smart contract code
nodes run smart contract codes on a
ethereum virtual machine it is a virtual
machine designed to operate as a runtime
environment for ethereum based smart
contracts evm is operated in a sandbox
environment or isolated from the main
net and it is a perfect testing
environment so you can download the evm
run your smart contact locally in an
isolated manner and once you have tested
and verified it then you can deploy it
on the main now very important and a
very good question what is a dab and how
is it different from a normal
application we need to understand these
differences very thoroughly in order to
clear our interview so adap is a
decentralized application which is
deployed using smart contract the
information on a dap is distributed and
shared in a normal application it has a
centralized database which is running on
a centralized server so you have a
single server and a single code which is
maintaining the entire application no
information is shared and it is a single
point of failure adapt has its back-end
code a smart contract which runs on a
decentralized peer-to-peer network in a
normal application it's a typical
computer software application that is
hosted on a central server so if you see
in the differences in the process you
have a front end then in the middle you
have a smart contract which is acting as
the back end code and then the entire
transaction executed on a smart contract
is shared between the blockchain
participants in a p2p network whereas in
a normal application the front end
interacts with a centralized api which
performs basic crud operations create
read update delete on a centralized
database and it is a single copy of the
information name some leading open
source platforms for developing
blockchain applications so ethereum is
one of the popular platforms for
building blockchain-based applications
and it is widely getting adopted ares is
also used for building enterprise-based
solutions and also some of the widely
used platforms for building blockchain
are listed below hyperledger multi-chain
open chain are available in the market
what is the very first thing you must
specify in a solidity file now it is
necessary to specify the version number
of solidity at the beginning of a code
as it eliminates incompatibility errors
which can arise while compiling with
another version it is a mandatory clause
which has to be there at the top of any
solidity code which you write and you
need to mention the correct version
number for which you have written the
code now what is the difference between
bitcoin and ethereum and it's a very
important question which i also ask in a
lot of interviews and it's important for
you to remember these differences so
bitcoin the concept is purely p2p
currency based transaction but in
ethereum you can do both p2p currency
transaction plus you can deploy smart
contracts bitcoin is primarily working
on proof-of-work consensus mechanism
ethereum is shifting from proof of work
to proof-of-stake bitcoin uses sha-256
hashing algorithm whereas ethereum uses
it hash time taken to mine a block
currently on bitcoin is approximately 10
minutes whereas in ethereum it gets
processed in 12 to 15 seconds the reward
for mining on bitcoin as of today is
12.5 bitcoin whereas in ethereum it is
three ethers plus the transaction fees
on bitcoin the transaction fees are
optional whereas in ethereum the fees is
calculated based on the gas which is
being consumed on a smart contract per
transaction value of bitcoin as of 21st
august was captured at
6934 us dollars whereas ethereum stands
at 278
now what is nonce and how is it used in
mining in blockchain mining is a process
to validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now proof of work is the
process to determine a number a nonce
that is the number along with the
cryptographic hash algorithm to produce
a hash value which is lower than a
predefined target nonce is a random
value which is used to vary the hash
value so that the final hash value meets
the hashing condition so the nonce is
the value which is being generated by
the miner in order to guess the hash
value which should be less than the
target value and then only the miner can
claim the reward for if he's mining a
bitcoin network of 12.5 btc and an
ethereum network of three ethers now
let's look at some of the advanced level
questions name the steps that are
involved in a blockchain project
implementation so in a typical
blockchain based project implementation
we start off with requirement
identification we need to understand the
problem and goal we need to identify the
suitable consensus mechanism what is the
most suitable platform which can solve
the problem and then identify the
implementation and deployment cost we
need to give an roi to the client then
we move on to the planning stage in this
step an individual evaluates all the
requirements list them down prioritize
them and decide a suitable blockchain
platform which has to be used to
implement this particular problem then
kicks off the development and
implementation of the project you design
the architecture you design the user
interfaces and start building the apis
and then comes controlling and
monitoring the project you apply the
proof of concept you start off with that
and then start building the application
on top of it and then once the basic
version of the application is available
you start identifying bugs and start
fixing them explain a real life use case
where blockchain is being used so supply
chain is the biggest adopter of
blockchain and as you can see as the raw
material moves is exchanged between
different entities in a supply chain the
traceability of that particular digital
asset which in this case is raw material
is a big case study on blockchain in
supply chain management smart contracts
provide permanent transparency
traceability and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain partners so at each level each
supply chain partner has to register a
transaction when it receives a product
and then when it passes it on so
basically the purchaser when consuming
the end product can see the entire
journey of the product list and explain
the parts of evm memory so the memory of
an evm is divided into three parts
storage memory and stack storage values
are stored permanently on the blockchain
network and it is extremely expensive so
whenever you will try to modify a
storage based variable you would have to
pay gas for it memory variables are
temporary modifiable storage area it can
be accessed only during the contract
execution and once the execution is
finished the data is wiped off vanished
and lost stack on the other way is a
temporary and a non-modifiable storage
here when the execution is completed the
content is lost so basically memory and
stack are relatively much cheaper than
storage variables now what happens if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas initially
your transaction will be executed but if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas then the
miners will stop validating your
contract the blockchain will record the
transaction as fail as highlighted and
also the user does not get a refund so
it becomes of utmost important that when
you are deploying your smart contract
you do the calculation of the gas
consumption in the most correct fashion
what does the gas usage in a transaction
depend on and how is transaction fee
calculated so gas usage depends upon the
amount of storage you are using if you
are using storage based variables and
the cost of the transactions will be
high the gas will be high and the set of
instruction codes use in a smart
contract basically what operations you
are performing on the storage based
variables either they are costly and if
you are using huge amount of storage
variables then automatically the cost of
your smart contract will keep on
increasing so basically the transaction
fee is calculated in ethers which is
given as the gas price which you have
determined for your smart contract and
multiplied by the gas limit and this is
how your transaction fee is evaluated
now what is fork and what are some of
the types of forking so in simple terms
updating a cryptocurrency protocol or
code is called forking fork implies that
a blockchain splits into two branches
and forking is done when you want to
modify certain attributes of an existing
blockchain network it can happen when
the participants of the network cannot
come to an agreement with regards to
either the consensus algorithm or they
want new rules for validation so there
are three types of forking heart forking
soft forking and accidental forks what
is the difference between proof of work
versus proof of stake and it's a very
important question in blockchain proof
of work is the process of solving a
complex mathematical puzzle called
mining whereas proof of stake is an
alternative proof of work by which the
blockchain aims to achieve distributed
consensus in proof of work probability
of mining a block is based upon the
amount of computational work done by a
miner basically it consumes huge amount
of resources electricity resources and
computational resources of the miner
whereas in proof of take the probability
of validating the block relies upon the
amount of token you own beforehand so
the more the tokens you have the more
the chance you get to validate a block
so basically proof of stock has been
introduced in order to reduce the
pressure on the resources which has been
put by the proof of work consensus
algorithm miners spend a lot of
computing power for solving the
cryptographic puzzle along with the
hardware and it's a huge cost so
basically proof of stake was created as
a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources spent in mining what
is a 51 attack in blockchain 51 attack
refers to a vulnerability where an
individual or group of people can
control the majority of the mining power
or hash rate so basically they can take
over the 50 of the blockchain network
this would allow the attackers to
prevent new transactions from being
confirmed further they can double spend
the coins now in 51 attack smaller
cryptocurrencies are primarily being
attacked which does not have a huge
network which has a small consumer base
water function modifiers and solidity
and mention the most widely used
modifiers in solidity function modifiers
are used to easily modify behavior of
your smart contract it can be associated
with a function and then whenever a
function is called the modifier is
called before the main function in
simple terms it can build additional
features or apply restrictions on the
function of smart contracts the most
extensively used function modifiers in
solidity are view view functions are
functions that cannot modify the state
of a smart contract they are only read
only functions here is an example you
have a function get simply learn name
and it is having a modifier view which
only returns a value but you are allowed
to use some inbuilt solidity functions
like msg.sender but in case of pure pure
functions are functions that neither
read nor write the state of smart
contracts they return the same result
determined by its input variables so
basically you can't even access the
inbuilt functions of solidity so here
you have a function called calculate you
can only use the input variables you
cannot use any of the inbuilt functions
also of solidity now let's take a look
of an example in order to write a
crowdsale smart contract code in
solidity programming language so here in
the example you have a smart contract
where you have defined certain smart
contract variables of solidity like
address and uint now the address
function is if you want to send your
token to someone and your uint is the
funding goal in ethers basically how
much amount of ethers you want to
generate in your crowdsale
project then what is the duration of
your project then cost of each token in
ethers then address of token used as
reward so these are the primary
attributes which you have defined then
you have your public functions which are
defined over here the beneficiary if
successfully sent to the funding goal
the deadline of your crowd sale and the
price now here is your default function
which is defined in a solidity contract
which does not have any function name
and is called by default in your smart
contract if anyone invokes a method in
your smart contract which does not exist
in this function you are making sure
that all the amount which has been
passed to the smart contract is passed
to your address basically you are the
originator of your crowdsale function
crowdsale smart contract so you should
be receiving the amount then in your
crowdsales smart contract you can have a
method which is called as safe
withdrawal and you have appended it with
a modifier called after deadline so
which basically
checks that you can only do a withdrawal
after the deadline has been achieved and
in this function you are checking the
balance then you are withdrawing that
amount from the sender and transferring
it to your own account as the sender has
sent that amount to you so you do the
basic validations whether the sender has
that balance and then you do that
transfer to your account i hope you all
had a great session and i'll meet you in
my next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here